E
NOT TRG  OF COURSE IF HE WINS W
THAT COOK LIKE.
>> THE FORMEDID MAKE
BRHICH HE'S ON NOW.
I JUST WANT TO PLAY YOU WHAT HE
SAID.
>> WL,ERY MUCH IERICA, AND IT WH
C. ANDFIH AND
THE DECA THEBUILDINGS AND WALLS
GRAFFITI.
ENS  A OE TH 'S A VERY D THG  S
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
IS THE   THAADING BY V IN AMER.
UBSTANTIALUME
REPUBLICAN P ANDDING
BIDEN BY A LOT.
ASHINGTO DN ECAUSE6th.HAENE FORF
TH IE  BEHIND.
>> WE'VE HEARD THIFR
TRUMP EVERSINGLE TE.T USED T P
HE CONTINUES TO AND WILLCONTINO
MALD AUTORS, LAWMEJUDGANE
I THLL IT
OUT EVERY TIME, FIRST OFFOBEIRR
DAN
DANGEROUS.
ERE WILL  ISTEN TOWORDS,N TH
BECCOFHES AL JUSTICE SYSTEM, TH.
THERS  A
PROFESSIONS IN THIS WORLD WHER
EBODY SAYS YOU
WIVE A.
HEE FORMER ACTIN
THEELTION'T KNOW O  TRIAL BEFOD
DONALD'S TEAM HAS
MATED THE
ONTHS.THAT HIGH.R,S NOWHERE NEAO
FI MONTHSO LET C HALF.FOUR MTH.
I DON'T KNOWRE
-MONTHLE
SAY ITIFFERENTLY.
THERE IS A FR OR
STVE-MONTH OPE THE  GIVEN TNG
MANHATTAN, THE HUSSE,
THATARPRRIGHT AFTER THAT THE-A .
'L JULY.
URR
P  REALISTICALLY TRY
HOWEVER, THOSE TRIAL DATES CAN
TRIAL DAS  TCKINLY
F HIUT.
IT'S ULTATA , WHAT DO YOU THINK
GOING TOK.MON FO
AND WORK OUT S-
>> CERTAINLYMS
BRAGG WOULD BE
SOMETHINT HOLD.
>> AGAIN, IT'SP TOJUHAND IA
UDGE AND I'M SUR
DGE KAJUDGE
MARCHAND TO GO FIRST I'M
LULY
ALLOW THAT TO
AT HAPPENED ON
AUSTh WHEN THEY ND SET TRIAL DA
AND THEY'LL ALSO
TICTICE, WHICHOU
T ALL
HEENCY SNGYO
FAM VENUE, ALOF THE
INF COUNSEL,
ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO ARGUE ABOUT THI
E JUDGE
HAVEO SUBMITHON MOTIAN THEY'LL
MOTIONS AND THEN SET A
DATE.D THAT WILETWEEN SEPTEMBER
NO REASON  CT
F.
D WITH CLASSIFIED  WAS SAYINBEFO
DOCUMENTS THE Y ARE IN
TH CAR
JACK SMITH WILL
RNHE DISCOVERY OVER.
THEY'LL HIGHLIGHT FOEM
IS
BUT E ART RTS, LOOK HERE
>> IT SES THAT JACK SM
TEAM IREADY TO HAND OVER AN
FUL LOT OF EVIDEAND
CUTHAT THEY HAVE TO THE
DEFENSE.
>>H,IN THEASA
DONTS HAVEN'T BEENOVER BECAUSE .
AND SO THEYERS GET TOP
TH'SPP A
EVENOV SOME OF THE SCOVER T-LAG
HAVE THOSEES.
>>OWO ON WILL LAST? EY.PENUY,
ECOW LONDOU R SCIENCE TOTHWI LG,
REVE SEEN ES WRE
EVERNEE IN D, WO GET O H
THIS THING TRIEDO MONTHS, REIT'.
OVER THAT AS WELL.UGH, LY DOES C
LOG TO BE SO
IS TIMING. WT  A
ELECTION?
LLY?E THE POLITICA
WILLT CHANGE ?
CERT THAT A NOT
GO UTILIZE E DTA AON -- ARE NGE
YOU ABLE TO MAKE ANY KIND OF OF?
>> A IW
BIE TALKT AN ELE
YEAR WHERE WT TALK  STUE CREDIT
T THAT.
UFOsCAN'T TALK ABOUT
THERE'S 30LIUNNGT TRUMP INHIIMA.